At this very second, you are on a narrow ledge between life and death.
You probably don't feel it,
but there's an incredible amount of activity going on inside you.
And this activity can never stop picture yourself.
As a slinky, falling down an escalator, moving upwards,
the falling part represents the self-replicating processes of yourselves.
The escalator represents the laws of physics driving you forwards
to be alive is to be in motion, but never arriving anywhere.
If you reach the top of the escalator,
there's no more falling possible and you are dead forever,
somewhat. Unsettlingly the universe wants you to reach the top.
How do you avoid that? And why are you alive?
[Inaudible].
All. Life is based on the cell.
A cell is a piece of the dead universe that separated itself from the rest.
So it could do its own thing for a while. When this separation breaks down,
it dies and joins the rest of the dead universe. Again,
unfortunately,
the universe would like for life to be done with doing its own thing.
For some reason, it's not a fan of exciting things,
but tries to be as boring as possible.
We call this principle entropy, and it's a fundamental rule of our universe.
It's pretty complicated. And counter-intuitive so we'll explain it in detail.
In another video for now,
all you need to know is living things are inherently exciting.
A cell is filled up with millions of proteins and millions,
more simpler molecules like water.
Thousands of complex self-replicating processes are happening up to hundreds of
thousands of times, every second to stay alive and exciting.
It has to constantly work to keep itself from achieving entropy and becoming
boring and debt.
The cell has to maintain the separation from the rest of the universe.
It's doing this for example,
by keeping the concentration of certain molecules different on the inside and
the outside by actively pumping out excess molecules to do stuff like
this. A cell needs energy.
Energy is the ability of things in the universe to do work,
to move or manipulate a thing to create change
visibility cannot be created or destroyed.
The set amount of energy in the universe will never change.
We don't know why it just is that way. So billions of years ago,
one of the most crucial challenges for the first living beings was to get usable
energy. We don't know a lot about the first cells,
except that they got their energy from simple chemical reactions and they found
the ultimate energy transfer system, the energetic building block of life,
the molecule adenosine triphosphate or ADP it
structure makes it uniquely good at accepting and releasing energy.
When a cell needs energy, for example,
to pump out molecules or to repair a broken micro machine,
it can break down ATP and use the chemical energy to do work and create
change. This is why living beings are able to do stuff.
We don't know when or how exactly the first ATP molecule was made on earth,
but every living thing we know uses ATP or something very similar to keep
its internal machinery running.
It's crucial for almost every process plants,
funky bacteria and animals need to survive five
without ATP, no life on earth, possibly anywhere.
Breaking down chemicals for energy is nice and all early life did miss out
on the greatest available source energy, the sun,
the sun, mergers, atoms,
and radiates photons away the carry energy into the solar system.
But this energy is raw. And in there adjustable, it needs to be refined.
After hundreds of millions of years of evolution, finally,
a cell figured out how to eat.
The sun is absorbed radiation and converted much of it into neat metal
chemical packages that it could use to stay alive.
We call this process photosynthesis.
You take photons that are wobbly with electromagnetic energy and use a part of
this energy to merge and combine different molecules together.
The electromagnetic energy is converted into chemical energy stored in the
ATP molecule. This process became even better.
As some cells learn to create better chemical packages,
glucose or sugar,
easy to break down high in energy and pretty tasty.
This is so convenient that some cells decided that instead of doing all that
pesky photosynthesis work themselves,
they will just swallow other cells that days and take their glucose and ATP.
This is widely considered one of the biggest anime betrayals in evolutionary
history.
And so things went on photosynthesizing cells could mostly harness energy and
their surfaces, which limited their maximum energy production,
which limited that evolutionary Avenue somewhat. So time passed.
Some cells made sugar, others ate them. Evolution did its thing,
but overall things stayed pretty much the same for hundreds of millions and of
years until one day a cell ate another
and did not kill it. Instead, they became one cell,
nothing had changed that day, but earth would be different forever.
This cell became the ancestor of all animals on this planet.
Blue whales, amoeba dinosaurs, jellyfish, pink fairy,
armadillos, and Sunder colugos.
And of course you all can trace back their existence. To this moment.
The merging of two living beings is so important because when those two cells
became one, they became way more powerful.
The formerly independent cell in the inside could stop trying to survive.
It could concentrate on one thing, make ATP.
It became the powerhouse of the cell. The first mitochondria,
the host cells job became to ensure survival in the dangerous world and provide
the mitochondria with food mitochondria,
basically reverse photosynthesis in a similarly complex process.
They take sugar molecules that we got from eating, other living things,
combust them with oxygen and precursor molecules to make new energy rich
ATP molecules.
This process works like a tiny furnace and spits out waste products like CO2
water and a little bit of kinetic energy that you experience as body heat.
This first division of labor,
the new cell had way more energy available than any cell before,
which meant more possibilities for evolution to enable wall complex sounds.
At some point,
these cells began to form small groups or communities which led to multicellular
life. And finally to you today,
you are a pile of trillions of cells. Each filled with dozens.
If not hundreds of little machines that provide you with usable energy to stay
alive. If this process is interrupted, even for a few minutes,
you die. But if life is so fragile,
wouldn't it be a good idea to store ATP? Like we store sugar in our fat cells,
so we don't die. If we stop breathing for a while,
if life has solved so many problems to make you live today,
what's up with the dying quickly thing.
Even simple bacteria like e-coli make about 50 times their body weight in
ATP for every cell division.
Your trillions of cells need a lot of ATP to keep you around
every day.
Your body produces and converts about 19 million billion,
billion molecules of ATP about your own body weight.
You need a whole person's worth of ADP just to make it through a single day.
Even storing enough ATP to last you a few minutes is basically impossible.
An ATP molecule is really good for shifting energy around quickly,
but it's terrible for storage sends.
It has only 1% of a glucose molecules energy at three times its mass.
So ATP is constantly produced and used out fairly quickly.
This was the short and simplified story of the molecule that allows you to be
different from the dead universe and to be the slinky on the escalator.
It is a weird story.
There is this molecule you need to survive at all times.
You need it to keep moving because even a short break brings your slinky to a
stop and you need to make it yourself.
It's like driving a car at full speed while producing fuel in the trunk with
junk that you pick up from the side of the road.
As far as we know this all began billions of years ago when tiny parts of the
dead universe came together and became something else for a moment,
it could keep itself going. It could grow that moment,
set the slinky in motion.
And it's been going ever since from the very first cells to you
watching this. Now,
at some point you will merge with the rest of the debt universe. Again,
maybe you'll tell it stories about your adventures, maybe not,
but before you find out you get to do what knife does best
making a dead universe much more interesting.
If you are currently bored for whatever reason,
and you want to make your life more interesting, we've got something for you.
We partnered with Skillshare,
an online learning community that offers thousands of classes for all skill
levels on tons of creative skills like illustration, animation, cooking,
creative writing,
or film and video learning something while creating stuff for yourself is
pretty fun and fulfilling. If you want to learn animation,
we made a few Skillshare classes where we explained how we animated scenes from
our videos with video lessons and hands-on projects,
you can get unlimited access to all classes for less than $10 a month with an
annual premium membership.
And the first 1000 coats cause out viewers to click the link in the description.
We'll get a two month free trial.
And if you're just getting started for beginners who want to dip a toe into
illustration, similar to ours,
we recommend vector illustration using creative constraints to find your style
by Rick Bertelsmann. Just try something to improve your skills.
And at the same time fight the boredom of being stuck inside.
If you want to get creative with new skills and support coats,
cause I'd give it a try.
[Inaudible].